[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la rapporteur madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues je
souhaiterais aborder la cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale pour
répondre aux besoins croissants de
financement l'objectif de dépenses de la
branche de l'autonomie pour 2023 s'élève
à 37,3 milliards d'euros en augmentation
de 5,3% par rapport à l'année précédente
je tiens à souligner deux points
importants prévention et vieillir à
domicile d'abord le pvss pour 2023
accorde une importance particulière à
une meilleure prévention avec la mise en
place de rendez-vous de prévention à
certains sages clés de la vie sans pour
autant le rendre obligatoire chez
adultes de 60 65 ans ce rendez-vous
permettra de prévenir les malades
chroniques les troupes de vision les
fragilités ou la perte d'autonomie j'ai
déposé un amendement visant à repérer
les aidants lors de ses rendez-vous et
de prévenir les conséquences de la
situation des dents sur leur état de
santé ensuite le pdfss pour 2023 donne
priorité au vieillir à domicile le plus
longtemps possible pour les personnes
âgées en perte d'autonomie vivre ces
vieillir rien de plus écrivez Simone de
Beauvoir dans l'invité rappelons que 90%
des Français souhaite vieillir et être
accompagnés dans leur vieillissement ou
leur handicap à domicile afin de
répondre à cette attente de la société
civile quelques mesures phares ont été
prises l'article 33 vise à sécuriser la
réforme de la tarification des services
de soins infirmiers à domicile qui
devraient entrer en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2023 aussi 4000 places
supplémentaires seront créées l'article
34 permet au département de compléter
voire de dépasser le plafond des plans
d'aide personnalisées à l'autonomie par
deux heures d'accompagnement et de temps
social lorsque cela est nécessaire même
si cette mesure représente une avancée
importante et va dans l'intérêt des
professionnels ainsi que des personnes
âgées les sénateurs union centrices
regrettent profondément son périmètre
restreint uniquement au bénéficiaire de
la part excluant de facto les
bénéficiaires de la prestation de
compensation du handicap
par ailleurs les plans d'aide
actuellement tendus des bénéficiaires de
lapins ne permettant pas de répondre en
tout ou partie au gestes de la vie
quotidienne dont ils ont besoin il est à
craindre que ces heures ne se limitent
qu'à répondre à des besoins vitaux pour
les personnes âgées au détriment des
heures de lien social pourtant
nécessaire par conséquent nous nous
interrogeons sur la soutenabilité de son
financement par les départements malgré
les besoins grandissant de la population
d'avoir recours au service à la personne
le secteur a forte intensité de main
d'oeuvre et confronté à de vivre tension
en recrutement sur l'ensemble des
métiers en ce sens un million d'emplois
sont à pouvoir d'ici à 2030 toutefois le
Pelve 16 pour 2023 ne contient aucune
mesure à application immédiate pour ce
secteur le texte présente des éléments
positifs comme le bouclier inflation et
le bouclier énergie il faudra élargir le
bouclier énergie au service à domicile
pour lesquels les factures descend se
pèsent lourdement surtout dans les
territoires ruraux pour améliorer la
prise en charge des personnes âgées dans
les EHPAD ce projet de loi on voit
plusieurs mesures revalorisation
salariale actualisation des coupes Patos
déploiement de centres de ressources
territoriaux la simplification des
modalités de financement de l'habitat
inclusif l'aide à la vie partagée est
une bonne solution qui retardera les
entrées dans les EHPAD par ailleurs les
EHPAD vont bénéficier de 3000
aides-soignants et affirmiers
supplémentaires en 2023 même si ces
annonces vont dans le bon sens une
réflexion sur des problèmes rencontrés
par le secteur Saverne nécessaire
attractivité formation VAE postes
vacants comment donner envie à des
femmes et à des hommes de s'engager dans
des services d'aide à domicile de
devenir auxiliaire de vie ou infirmier
en pratique avancée
spécialisé en géant gâterie nous saluons
enfin l'inscription du Bien vieillir
dans le concert national de la
refondation adapter la société au
vieillissement provoque promouvoir la
citoyenneté des personnes âgées et le
lien social revaloriser les métiers sont
les trois axes du CNR dédiés à la
thématique du Bien vieillir
10 ateliers de concertation sont prévus
dans 10 départements de métropoles et
d'outre-mer la feuille de route issue de
la concertation sera présenté en mai
2023 je profite de cette occasion pour
mettre l'accent sur la participation des
aidants à ces échanges et la nécessité
de l'amélioration des mesures en faveur
du répit qui jouent un rôle important
dans la lutte contre l'isolement social
des personnes âgées ou handicapées en ce
qui concerne les aidants les articles 34
bis et terre du PLFSS 2023 que le
gouvernement a choisi de retenir en
faisant usage usage du 49-3 trade de
l'élargissement de la durée de
l'indemnisation du congé proche aidant
ainsi que de l'identification des moyens
d'élargir la location journalière du
procédant aux aidants des personnes
malades du cancer le gouvernement
propose de nous remettre des rapports
sur ce sujet je soutiendrai leur
maintien dans le texte sachant que
moi-même je lui ai demandé depuis
plusieurs années l'article 35 terre issu
d'un amendement ouvre d'une expiration
permettant la création d'un véritable
parcours d'accompagnement harmonisé des
aidants familiaux toujours et notamment
passer par la prise en charge d'une
consultation médicale spécifique
rappelons aussi qu'une politique de
l'autonomie ne se réduit pas au grand
âge et au Bien Vieillir sur le chant du
handicap le PLFSS encourage à
transformation des établissements
médico-sociaux et promeut les démarches
inclusives nous nous réjouissons de
l'augmentation des moyens budgétaires
près de 70 millions d'euros destinés à
développer l'offre pour le public
atteint de troubles du spectre de
l'autisme je préférais parler de
troubles du neurodéveloppement afin de
mieux prendre en charge le TDAH et les
10 l'article 33 TER organise la
revalorisation annuelle du tarif
plancher qui passera à 23 euros en 2023
l'article 35 bis issu d'un amendement du
gouvernement crée un parcours de
rééducation et de réévaluation des
enfants en situation de polyhandicap ou
de paralysie cérébrale enfin nous
regrettons l'absence de présentation par
le gouvernement d'une loi grand âge et
le manque de projection plurielle
indispensable pour relever les défis de
cette branche
chers collègues le secteur médico-social
s'ouvre du contexte de l'inflation et de
la crise du recrutement des oubliés du
Ségur de la santé mettent en cause une
forte inégalité de traitement le temps
des constats et des propositions et
révolu il est l'heure d'élargir sur les
terrains de mettre en place un plan
d'action des dispositifs d'urgence et
des modalités concrètes je vous remercie
de votre attention merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Alain Milon du groupe les républicains
pour 8 minutes